ten yous been witness is on your screen
and this is his newest book law in the
long war the future of justice in the
age of terror
mr. witness how is the Bush
administration in your view done as far
as prosecuting the war on terror or the
long wars you call it well I mean you
know you have to start with the fact
that is often overlooked that in
September of 2001 I don't think many
Americans expected that we wouldn't be
hit in the homeland again over the next
seven years and I think they can rightly
take a lot of credit for that there we
know that there have been a lot of plots
or a number of plots foiled and some of
them have been very serious and I think
they they rightly get to claim a lot of
credit for that I I believe that a lot
of what they a lot of the controversy
that's developed over the law has
actually been unnecessary and had that
the reason for that is really a needless
aggression aggressiveness on their part
and a desire to do things that could
have been done collaboratively with the
legislature on their own and I think
they have to take a lot of
responsibility for that so I think you
know there's a lot of the things that
they wanted to do and did do are
probably much more defensible than the
manner in which they did them give some
examples of aggressive policy well for
example they wanted to conduct military
commission trials which was a very bold
experiment in sort of creating a new
trial system they tried to do it on
their own rather than going to Congress
and saying hey here's what we need to do
can you help can you pass a statute
authorizing this can you can you create
a framework for us to do this they
needed to detain a whole lot of people
people who we had caught overseas some
of them in very murky factual
circumstances some of them were going to
be candid about it who we didn't quite
know who they were and they might very
well have been you know non-combatants
or innocence instead of going to
Congress and saying hey we need you know
we need a legal framework in which do
these things there are some ugly things
we're going to need to do
we need help they just kind of said we
can do it on our own
both of these decisions has caused just
a world of litigation some of which was
probably inevitable a lot of it was not
inevitable there are other examples I
you know FISA FISA is certainly an
example you know and eventually with
respect to FISA they did you know go to
Congress and this just a few weeks ago
they got more or less what they needed
and and so I think one of the big
lessons here is when they actually go
through the exercise and work with
Congress Congress actually does even
when it's led by the opposition party
does actually give them not all of what
they want but certainly all of what they
need and does that provide political
cover and what else
by working this Congress the benefits
and this is the principle thesis of the
book the benefits of working with
Congress rather than sort of doing
things on your own are enormous
they requires a certain amount of
discipline up front but what it get what
you get in return is when you take these
very controversial actions these actions
that when you know that when they're
going to become public people are going
to say whoa it's the US government
really doing that that you get to say we
went to the Congress of the United
States we we asked how we should handle
these situations and they passed a law
that said X Y & Z and we did X Y & Z and
you get enormous political cover for
that and and I think that's why for
example a lot of the actions taken under
the Patriot Act which was the big
exception the situation where they did
go to Congress are understood to be much
more legitimate than the actions they
took outside of any statutory framework
how long have you been looking at this
issue of justice and the war on terror
well it's a it's an int you know it's
hard to actually pinpoint the start date
I got interested in FISA when I was a
young reporter at legal times in 1994
and I've been interested in sort of the
intersection of law and national
security and counter
ever since I when after 9/11 I was an
editorial writer at the Washington Post
and we ended up spending four obviously
huge amounts of time and energy on this
and I think the sort of bulk of my work
on the subject sort of dates from you
know from September 11th however it does
it does go back probably seven or eight
years earlier than that in your book on
page 152 in the chapter of the twin
problems of detention and trial this is
what you write as I argued earlier
habeas corpus review of detentions is
only significant in the absence of some
other cohesive system for evaluating
their legality what does that mean well
you know we always talk about habeas
when we won't think about Guantanamo
people people say the debate translates
very quickly into a debate over habeas
corpus should we have how robust should
the federal courts review of these
detentions be and we talk about two
things about Guantanamo mostly one is
should we close Guantanamo which is
really a question of a venue right I
mean should we hold them in Guantanamo
or should we hold them at somewhere else
right and we talked about the question
of habeas corpus and my argument is
these are both a sort of pair of tales
very small tails wagging a very big dog
and the dog is not you know what the
mechanism of review is going to be the
dog is that is the detention policy
itself who should we be holding outside
of a criminal justice apparatus what are
the rules under which we should be
detaining people outside of traditional
criminal trial what are the role of
judges and that what are the substantive
standards I mean what do you have to
prove about somebody what kind of
evidence can you use these are the
questions and when you focus on habeas
corpus you're focusing on this sort of
back end question which is okay so we've
gone through all that the executive
branch has decided who to detain and
what rules it's going to use and now the
judiciary is going to review it but but
I want a more intense and more serious
focus on the front end question
it's basically what are the rules going
to be and Congress has never tried to
answer those questions and I think if
you tried to answer those questions
seriously a lot of the habeas questions
would kind of take care of themselves
because the courts reviewing it would
look at these things and say here were
the rules did the executive follow the
rules yes they did okay the guys
detained no they didn't you got a
problem and but if you focus on that
back-end review mechanism instead of
instead of these front-end rules you're
going to end up with a lot of weight on
that litigation at the end of the day
are you satisfied with how the judiciary
system has changed or helped to
administer these laws no not at all
I'm not satisfied with the behavior of
the executive branch in trying to do
this stuff as I said before on its own
I'm not satisfied with the judiciary
which has I think really sought to carve
itself a place at the table in in the
litigations that have developed and I'm
not satisfied with the role of Congress
which has really sat back and and unlike
the other two branches not asserted
itself not done the job that we think of
as the job of the Congress of the United
States and in these situations the
result is the I have a sort of a vaguely
you know the we've decided to design
these systems in this kind of peculiar
dialogue between the executive branch
and the judiciary the executive tries
something it says you know here's what
we're going to do and the judiciary says
no you can't do that and then the
executive says okay here here's what
we're going to do and and the judiciary
says no that's that's not okay
and what doesn't happen you know in this
sort of very basic civics class fifth
grade kind of way you know you say if
you have gas any high school civics
group or fifth grade civics class right
you have a new problem that America has
really never faced before and you got to
create a whole lot of new rules what's
the body of government that's supposed
to do that and I think you could
probably get 80% of fifth graders
without prompting them too much to say
to Congress and that's the body that's
been the least in
that's been the most reactive the most
unimaginative and so I actually think
there's a lot of blame to go to all
three branches of government here law in
the long war the future of justice and
the age of terror is the book then
witness is the author New Iberia
Louisiana Democrat your first up yes
good morning gentlemen there's a
question that I've been wanting to ask I
heard a lieutenant on the news do you
know if we still have any American
troops in Saudi Arabia of post of one I
call her why do you ask that
well the reason I ask that is because of
Ed Bradley in his interview on the
desert with Osama bin Laden when he
declared war on the United States and
was asked why he declared war he said
because the troops were left India and
in the Holy Land and in Saudi Arabia
post Gulf one and that he won the
mountain the reason to declare war now I
remember
shortly after the Vietnam 11 attack it
was announced that we were moving all of
our troops from Saudi Arabia and I would
submit that's why we have a minute attic
and because it capitulated gave in to
him and called off the pursuit oh all
right Thank You caller I'm not sure if
that's mr. witnesses area of expertise
anything there that you wanted to
address I actually I couldn't hear the
question when it was done he's not
talking about troops in Saudi Arabia and
whether they're still there yeah I mean
I do not believe for a minute that al
Qaeda does not want to hit us again as
soon as it has a convenient opportunity
to do so let's use that opportunity of
that call to talk about renditions what
is rendition well rendition I in the in
the technical sense is merely the
capturing of somebody and the turning
him over to somebody else the the
circumstances in which it has become
controversial is really when you've kind
of kidnapped somebody or receive custody
of somebody abroad and then transfer him
to a foreign government in order to
depending on who's making the allegation
facilitate the
interrogation of the person or turn them
over to you know a sort of secret CIA
prison or something along those lines to
Priscilla to again to facilitate
interrogation and when it comes to your
book and your thesis how does that been
playing out well I mean one of the
things about the rendition program which
is that which is you know not I think
not widely appreciated is that it
actually is not a creature entirely of
this administration the rendition
program began in 1995 because the the
Clinton administration made a
determination that there were these you
know really scary al-qaeda people who
they were very interested in taking down
and they couldn't reach them by
conventional judicial process because
they were you know in parts of the world
in which people were very hard to get to
with with court orders and so they
started in a number of cases that have
you know that we now know about we're
really quite aggressive about it
the interesting thing about it is that
the current administration has kind of
ramped that up in a very dramatic way
but the basic policy is much more
similar than different with one big
exception which is under the Clinton
administration they would turn people
over to foreign governments who had
excellent judicial warrants for them
some of them were pretty farcical I
think but under the current
administration the CIA would hold people
themselves and it's an interesting kind
of philosophical question which is a
better and which is a worse approach but
the result of it the current
administration's decision was the CIA
ended up taking custody of a whole lot
of people that in the prior
administration it never would have held
New Castle Pennsylvania you're on with
in with us thank you very much for
taking my call
I just wanted to say a few things and
number one I spoke with a gentleman that
is actually in the service and he told
being there caller color I'm going to
I'm going to put you on hold
see if you can I don't know if you're on
a cordless or what but it's see if you
can get closer to your basin and get a
better connection because it gets a
little scratchy let's move on to
Springfield Virginia independent line
yes good morning and thank you very much
although mr. width I commend you highly
for coming up as far as happen I would
like you to be more truthful and pain to
the American people and to the world it
that this group of European Asst I've
been having people from what they called
us in expecting them sending them and
from George Washington to George Bush
there has never been a low full system
they have been kidnapping people
terrorizing torturing him here in this
what's called America's Airport the Bush
administration and they did cleaner
Enterprise has omitted the highest crime
anything other chip has ever committed
and I would like you to come for
possibly and please tell us about the
same
I am couldn't disagree more with the
tone and substance of what the caller
has said with one basic exception which
i think is worth dwelling which is that
he pointing out which is that he he
argues as i understand his point that
the there's a lot of continuity between
the current administration and prior
administrations and i actually think
that's correct i think the if you look
at the the rendition example that you
gave is one but there's actually a lot
of continuity between the last
administration and this administration
the caller thinks of that is it i guess
an indictment of both i think of it as
actually to some degree a defense of
both i think a lot of the programs that
you know we we think of as very
bush administration programs actually
have roots significantly earlier than
that and that's a in my mind a
reflection of the fact that you know
these are partly responses to
institutional need on the part of the
executive branch that is not you know so
unique as people think to the Bush
administration next call let's go back
to New Castle Pennsylvania Republican
New Castle go ahead I'm sorry about that
no problem okay what I wanted to say was
that I spoke with a gentleman who's
actually in the service and he's been to
Iraq twice and he said you know when he
hears the news media saying about these
weapons of mass destruction that there
were none he said there certainly was
weapons of mass destruction I was part
of that and he said if people could only
know what is actually going on over
there you know the real truth he said
this you know that he said I'm not
saying nothing about one candidate or
the other candidate for what I am saying
is the the Bush administration does
deserve a lot of credit for what they
have done over there he said they have
built schools the children are being
educated he said the women are allowed
to come out of their homes they can vote
now
he said there's so many positive things
going on in that country which is going
to be a plus for us he said these people
were being educated and understand how
to live properly in society instead of
the way they were living so he said that
needs to be understood and he said you
know I can't talk to enough people to
tell them because he said that's how I
feel about it so this is what I'm
worried about our election in November
we really need to put someone back into
that office that's going to keep our
country safe I don't want the fighting
here I have a family and I don't want
that fighting and going on over here
Thank You Palin let's leave it there mr.
with us anything there you'd like to
respond to not really my book isn't
really about Iraq it's it's about
domestic American law and the rules that
we need in order to prosecute the war on
terrorism both effectively and in a
fashion consistent with our values and
would let's say senator Obama gadelle
elected do you think there'd be a
radical change in how the war the long
Wars prosecuted I think there certainly
be a change in tone I think you know the
FISA debate is actually a good example
of what I think there will be that I
think there will be less change than
people imagine either you know it's very
easy when you're out of power and you're
you know not part of the daily threat
reporting and you don't have to figure
out you know what to do in response to
very specific problems that arise to
take you know it's very opposite of
oppositional positions with respect to
administration policy I think the closer
you get to being the president the more
disciplining that is and the using
yourself in that role is and I think the
FISA vote is a is a harbinger of things
to come for example I don't believe that
you know when Barack Obama becomes
president if that happens you know we're
going to stop detaining people I want to
read a couple sentences from your book
and tell us whether or not these got you
in trouble with anybody those and talk
about torture coercive interrogation
techniques as you call them those who
have used conventional interrogation
tactics successfully believe them
optimal those who have used more
coercive tactics successfully believe
them optimal there has been surprisingly
little study of the relative efficacy of
different modes of interrogation we know
hardly anything about what really works
yeah I mean I think you know a lot of
people are uncomfortable with that idea
but I actually think it's it's well
supported you know if you when you when
you listen to the CIA or for that matter
the president statements about the high
value program they are very convinced
that they got information that they
could not have gotten from by
conventional means when you speak to
interrogators in the military system in
the FBI in you know they're horrified by
this stuff and and they really believe
that the only good intelligence you ever
get in the long run comes from
sort of the development of rapport with
detainees and and treating people well
and kind of gaining their trust over
time and you know the academic
literature there's a very large report
produced by the intelligence Science
Board called adducing information which
tries to survey this entire field and
sort of figure out what we know it's
basic conclusion was we don't know what
works we don't know whether the coercive
stuff works we don't even know whether
the tactics that have been approved for
military use for the last 50 years the
non-coercive stuff we don't know how
well they work either
they say the evidence is all anecdotal
and the weight of the anecdotal evidence
tends to disfavor the use of coercive
techniques but that's that's the
strongest statement that they're able to
muster I'm sorry I think the the reality
is that we really have a very limited
sense about what of what coercive
techniques do and don't do so in your
view mr. Widow speed the discussion that
we've been having for a year or so on
waterboarding sidebar or important
central issue well it's important in the
sense that you know we do have to define
the limits of what we're going to do and
you know waterboarding is the farthest
out stuff we've done so it is important
to to figure out is that you are we
going to go that far I think it's also a
sidebar in the sense this is three
detainees who we've used this particular
technique on and the much broader
question is what the baseline rules are
going to be for detainees in general
both in the military system and in the
CIA system secondly under what
circumstances of any circumstances
you're going to allow breaches of those
rules I think you know if you focus too
much on waterboarding what happens is
you take waterboarding off the table and
you go to the next particularly nasty
coercive technique and you don't really
answer the more foundational questions
of what you what you will and won't do
except it you won't do waterboarding
next call for been witness comes from
Paris France go ahead Paris I meet the
Whitaker I was actually calling you
regard
the response to the question of
rendition and when the US first got
involved with this it is knowledge
common knowledge here in France that the
Jefferson administration back in 1802
was instrumental in capturing Toussaint
L'Ouverture and filling him you know he
was the person the first person to
conquer Falls doing that 19th century
during that era the point I'm making is
the US has a hot long long history of
rendition and sending people to
countries where weather you know even
you know how these things work
so the idea that Clinton is responsible
I think knowledge I don't buy that this
is as a caller called earlier mentioned
this is something that our history is
littered with I'm sure we look closer
thank you
let me clarify my point was not that the
United States had never engaged in
activities that you know meet the
definition of a rendition prior to 1995
point is that the the program devoted to
taking down al-qaeda leadership by you
know and and and sort of international
terrorist figures using you know using
by rendering them to countries at which
would be willing to take them began in
1995 according to testimony by one of
the CIA officers who was responsible for
it next call Jackson New Jersey Democrat
you're on with been with us hello the
width hi Roma first time caller and I
know charge your book says law and a
long war however a lot of laws were
being broken we it became a situation
why we went to the war in the first
place so why hasn't anybody you know
continued to then President Bush end and
your dick training to our test for the
laws that were broken and Eliza they
told for why we went to war in the first
place
and I'll just wait on your answer
well again the book is not about Iraq
it's not about the question of why we
went to war in Iraq it's not about even
the question of why we went to war in
Afghanistan it's really about
prospectively if you if it's both an
analysis of how we got to our sort of
present impasse over what the rules
should be in the war on terrorism and
how we should make those rules and in
addition it's about sort of intellectual
and legal strategies for breaking that
impasse and sort of thinking about more
constructively over say the next 10
years about how to handle these problems
that we've struggled with so much as a
society problems like interrogation
detention renditions how we're going to
try those terrorists suspects that we're
going to try and you know one of the
interesting things in January 2002 sort
of when we first started you know
bringing large numbers of people to
Guantanamo we had this you know we
didn't know what the rules were going to
be for detention we didn't know what the
rules were going to be for trial we
didn't know what the rules were going to
be for interrogation and today you know
seven years later we still don't really
know what the rules are going to be for
detention trial surveillance or were a
little closer on surveillance than we
were there are these big questions that
we've made remarkably little progress in
answering and that's what this book is
about sort of how we failed to do that
and how we might do better in the future
you right that this was your most
difficult project of your career were
you surprised at some of the conclusions
that you came to yes I think the I
expected walking into it to think to to
believe at the end that I was certain
what some of the answers were and you
know I say in the introduction that this
is a rough sketch of a first draft of of
what might be a more coherent legal
architecture and I was that is not sort
of like false modesty or false humility
it
it is a sense of of you can live in
these issues and and for a very long
time and not feel at the end of it that
you're certain what the answers to them
are they're exceptionally difficult
problems Queens New York you're on with
been with us long the long Warren hi hi
I appreciate I appreciate mr. witnesses
a balanced view I just want to push you
a little bit if I may um David number
one do you think that the administration
didn't seek statutory authority for the
simple reason that they were concerned
about security reasons the not to let
the enemy know how they were going to be
treated who was actually captured that
sort of thing
number two do you think the Democrats
have been have been demagoguing this
whole issue for political gain because
we knew we do know that Pelosi and some
other selected Democrats were
continually briefed on the matter they
didn't object to the president write to
the president call the president say we
have a problem with this are they
complicit mr. wickham let me take the
first question first I think the the
answer is that a series of distinct sort
of themes pushes in the direction of not
going to Congress the first is yeah
there were some genuine security
concerns I think when you when you look
on at the FISA side it's actually very
hard to have a debate about that without
giving away a lot of information about
you know how we conduct electronic
surveillance and I think there were some
not illegitimate concerns in that regard
the other factor which is I suspect in
in in the big picture the more important
factor is that the administration does
have a very strong philosophical
commitment to the idea of executive
power and to the idea that anything the
president needs to do to protect the
country he can do without asking
permission from Congress and you know I
think the these two things there are
practical reasons why it's inconvenient
to go to Congress or you know in some
cases you have to give stuff up
in order to go to Congress you know in
whether its intelligence methods or you
know in the case of interrogation the
sort of details of what you're doing
which can be both embarrassing and can
also allow the enemy to train to those
techniques it kind of that those sort of
convenience factors and sort of
anxieties about security questions merge
with a very quite distinct philosophical
position that you don't have to do it
and in fact if you do it if you go ask
permission you're implying that Congress
could say no and these I think together
produce a very sort of toxic lack of
desire to engage the legislature in a
serious way
the answer to your second question is I
look I think a lot of people have
demagogues these questions and I don't
you know I don't it's in the nature of
politicians and legislators in general
to try to take credit for things that go
well and try to avoid responsibility for
things that go badly and I think one of
the things that is important about
engaging Congress seriously upfront in
these discussions and getting the
legislature on the record behind the
policies that you articulating behind
the controversial things that you're
going to do is that you then don't have
this question after the fact about you
know whether you had you know who was
briefed who was you know who wrote a
letter or memo to the file saying this
is a problem where this isn't a problem
you want the rules to be clear and you
want the safe harbor of the rules and
this is a was an incredibly
self-destructive failure on the
administration's part not to get that up
front time for a few more calls
Tampa good morning good morning morning
on the obably the only way we could stop
this war is talking the war in the White
House and that's just the bottom line we
can blame other countries or like we
always do for everything but we know the
truth about what really happened you can
look that Judge you heard with George
Bush parents in the wood before the
plane even hit up the
but what about the second plane nobody
stopped the question among that nobody
stopped the question of how he got into
the White House we're the ones that sit
by and look like fools
every time [ __ ] goes down then we try
to blame somebody else for something
well let's blame myself for a change I
have limited time for conspiracy there
is no an 11 Louisville Kentucky Democrat
yes first of all I really enjoyed
listening to c-span you've done a good
job
why are we so hesitant to impeach Cheney
Bush and and why do we give a president
such leeway to break laws constantly you
know there's a I think there's in the in
the talk of impeachment first of all
it's a it's a moot point at this point
there's no there's no prospect in the
last six months of and there's no
appetite on the Democratic side to you
know to engage that but but more
fundamentally it would be a remarkable
thing to impeach a president for acts
taken non corruptly in what he believed
and clearly he did believe was in the
necessary national security of the
United States and there are these times
in American history the most famous of
which is Lincoln's suspension of habeas
corpus where you know a president does
something that is either clearly extra
legal or almost clearly extra legal or
at least arguably extra legal and he's
hugely controversial and he says to the
people and the Congress and Lincoln gave
this incredible it's actually a message
to Congress I don't think it was a
speech in which he basically says look
if you think that this was improper I
here's how I disagree I think it was
proper but I'll stand on it I'll stand
fall on it in other words come get me
but if you think it was proper
then ratify it and the thing that people
forget about Lincoln suspension of
habeas corpus is that Congress then did
ratify it and they buckled very quickly
and so my my lesson from that is
actually different from the
administration's lesson might I my
lesson from that is you know when you
need to do something controversial and
something that you know is going to
ruffle a lot of feathers domestically
and internationally be willing to do it
as much in public as possible and and be
able to say I stand or fall on that
don't don't don't operate in secrecy and
one of the things that this
administration has done unfortunately is
it's insisted on a level of secrecy
that's inconsistent with that kind of
dialogue um but secondly put Congress in
that position challenge Congress and say
here's what I need to do you know if you
if you think I'm not allowed to do it
come and get me but if you think I
should it should do it I want your names
on it
and that's what you know look at the
difference between the FISA law as
Congress passed it which essentially
allows which was going was doing when he
actually does that he gets what he needs
did you interview members of the
administration for this book um the book
is is not fundamentally I mean I've
spoken to a lot of you know members of
the administration in the course of
working on the bush the book is
fundamentally not a work of reportorial
journalism with one exception which is
the sort of study of the Guantanamo
detainee population it's fundamentally
an analytical work that draws on
conversations that I've had over the
last 15 years including with a lot of
people in the current and former
administrations but it's not interview
is not quite the right word for it have
you had a chance to read a Jane Mayer's
new book I haven't yet it's out as of
last week and I'm going to turn to it
shortly Glenn Greenwald's book now
or his writings I've read much much of
his blog writings which you know which
which have you to take a very different
approach to these questions and then I
do
and John you I have read john use work
which I am NOT sympathetic to in the
sense that I missed you you is professor
you is a theoretician of the executive
power views of the Bush administration
which I I critique somewhat severely in
in the book he has two recent books that
one is sort of an academic exposition of
the theory and the other is a sort of
more popular account and which i think
is it's actually a good a good read for
people who are sort of interested in in
understanding the case that can be made
for the sort of extreme executive power
positions of the current administration
so somewhere between John you and Glenn
Greenwald is that where you are well I
you know I don't think of myself as on a
left-right spectrum
I think there's I'm interested in a in a
I hope the set of ideas in here will be
useful to as useful to a Barack Obama as
to a John McCain and and as useful to a
Nancy Pelosi as to a John Boehner it's
an attempt to try to think through what
what what the statutory law should be
that should guide us in these in these
areas and I don't know honestly if it
makes me a liberal or a conservative I
think five years ago these ideas would
have seemed quite liberal and these days
they seem more conservative and I'm not
sure quite why that is except that the
barkeeps
law in the long war is the book Citrus
Heights California you're on with Ben
with us
hey good morning morning Stu the
opportunity I think that you just kind
of sword into my comment or my thinking
on this when you talked about secrecy I
think that it the Bush administration
success in keeping us safe has really is
- you know the very thing that you kind
of don't like about them and that
secrecy you know it'd be great if we
could all sit around and talk about well
these are the limits these are the rules
we're not going to interrogate beyond
this limit we're not going to surveil
beyond that limit but is it useful for
the enemy to know all of that and it's
not it's obvious to me that it's not it
so these guys are very adaptable it's a
different type of war and it requires
different type of rules and and there
should be secrets and you know to the
extent that our government can
successfully keep secrets you know
they'll get more cooperation from other
intelligence agencies from other
countries that you know can also that
also managed to keep their secrets you
know they'll share there'll be more
forthcoming with us knowing that you
know hey tomorrow whatever they told us
isn't going to be on the front page of
the New York Times because of some
disgruntled scrub at the State
Department or in the CIA um so let me
take first of all that I I agree with a
component of that I I think that it is
extremely important to keep effectively
the secrets that you need to keep I do
think however that it does not help the
effort to do that when you're also
keeping secrets that you don't need to
keep it breeds contempt for secrecy and
it breeds an uncertainty and the part of
a lot of officials as to what's actually
really important to keep secret because
if everything is secret then nothing is
secret and so let me let me just try to
talk you out of your sense that the
answer to this question is obvious the
Guantanamo detainees the administration
resisted for a long time are identifying
who they were what it was alleging about
them what they said about themselves
unclassified records related to all of
that stuff existed and the
administration eventually
was forced to release that material in
the context of Freedom of Information
Act litigation with The Associated Press
interesting question had they released
that information prospectively actively
and said look here's who we're holding
here's why we're holding them would we
have the same controversy today that we
have a glove out Guantanamo chapter
three of my book looks at these cases
and I actually concluded in looking at
you know all you know 572 I believe of
these review tribunal transcripts that
were released that a lot of these people
there really shouldn't be much
controversy about their detention now
just query is that secrecy helpful to
the administration or is it hurtful to
the administration if I had been and
I've said this I'm not saying this
merely because I'm on c-span but I've
actually said to anybody who will listen
that they should have c-span in these
hearings they should be publicizing what
these people are saying what they're
being asked you know who they are
because it tends to narrow the dispute
and this is unclassified information the
hundun trial starts tomorrow and
Guantanamo apparently so yeah and it
looks like other trials will also that
the military is planning on proceeding
with other trials that's right I think
you know the the the military
commissions process has been you know
kicked around in various forms since
November of 2001 when the President
ordered that it be created and and the
failure to get it off the ground is one
of the the truly remarkable failures of
the post 9/11 you know justice system as
its developed the idea behind them it's
hard to can't even say this without a
smile back in 2001 was that these were
going to be you know relatively quick
and expeditious tribunals that we're
going to administer justice in a sort of
streamlined fashion and that really has
not happened and so far there's only
been one conviction and that was by
guilty plea and no case has yet gone to
trial and
so it's you know whether you believe
that these are illegitimate has a lot of
people do or believe as I do that
they're you know an experiment the
verdict is of which is yet in on and
that could be improved in some ways but
are but are basically sympathetic to the
idea that we need some kind of an
alternative trial venue for for some of
these cases it has not been a happy
experiment so far
last call for been witness comes from
New Castle Delaware independent yeah
yeah must say the guess is a Prius
Eiffel thank you I guess my concern is
really about added growth in executive
power over the over the over the ages
and the question really is about whether
or not you see any fear any legitimate
fear in a concern that perhaps the
aggressiveness in the in the use of the
executive branch power and executing all
rather prosecuting these terrorists is a
threat to a democracy or you think
democracy is strong enough to withstand
any aggressiveness so to speak and if
there's a president being set for
further growth in executive power it's
an excellent question and I'm going to
give a a somewhat paradoxical answer to
it which is but I think actually that
the irony of over broad assertions
exective executive power is that they
tend to provoke a backlash that actually
diminishes executive power and I think
that's to a large degree what's
happening with the Bush administration
that you know each of the last three
administrations Bush the first Bush
administration the Clinton
administration and the Bush to
administration has held detainees at
Guantanamo Bay in order to avoid
litigating their cases in federal court
and granting them all rights associated
with bringing them to the United States
in the case of the prior two
administrations they were refugees from
Cuba and
and Haiti not al-qaeda terrorists or
suspected al-qaeda terrorists only one
of these three administration is going
to leave office having made it
impossible for the next administration
to do the same thing and that's the bush
the second Bush administration you know
when you assert executive power too
broadly you trigger a judicial backlash
that then reigns in that executive power
and makes it more difficult for your
successors to to do even 70% of what you
tried to do the result and and and that
is I believe what what's happened here
the alternative which is what the vision
of executive power that I proposed in my
book is an executive power in which the
source of that power is not the sort of
chest-thumping you know macho assertions
that we get to do whatever we want to do
but in which the president goes to
Congress tells Congress what he needs to
do and Congress authorizes him to do
that set of things then he stands on
extremely powerful ground and those
assertions of executive power tend to be
very enduring but there's a catch he has
to engage with Congress up front in
order to get it so you have this very
interesting and delicate interplay
between the branches in which the source
of Congress of the source of the
executive power is Congress but the
triggering mechanism that causes
Congress to exercise its power to give
the president power is the request of
the President so I think you should
think about legislative and
congressional power in these areas as
deeply intertwined and when the
president tries to do it on his own in
the long run the presidency loses it
doesn't gain law in the long war the
future of justice in the age of terror
been witnesses the authors thank you for
being with us thanks for having me a
little over in half an hour left this
morning in the Washington journal we're
going to do two more things we're going
to open up the phone lines it's going to
be open